[Music]
you
hi there and welcome again to research
and focus I'm Gretchen using this week
Microsoft announced its new open network
emulator and today we get to talk to two
of the people who helped make it a
reality
Yibo Jew researcher and systems and
networking at MSR and marina lipstain
principal program manager in the azure
networking welcome to both of you thank
you so you represent two sides of an
exciting research project we just said
the open network emulator people you
worked on the research side of the
project what are the pain points
inherent in updating a network in
general and how does it get more
complicated at scale what does open
network emulator do and what problems
does it solve yeah so open network
emulator or one is the first time unit
that allows operators to test the
network changes before they deployed on
the point point is that right now our
crowd is going for very high reliability
and availability for example for nice or
five noise if you do the calculation you
will find within one year you may only
have a few minutes of downtime Wow and
to to achieve that we just can't afford
to you know deploy some changes to a
network and then find out figure out
that it's problematic and a robot which
is kind of folded so we want to make
sure every changes will allow is correct
and doesn't cause troubles so so we
build its emulator to help operators all
towards a true flat so you guys may
heard about a software-defined network
right but today the network is not
really developed but just type software
because in the software engineering you
have testing pipeline whenever you want
to go or something you will test it
before you really deploy but networks
don't have this such thing before one
and now we are developing these two so
that the operator can really develop the
network just start developing software
so in a general network update it's
problematic to begin with because you
don't know where it's going to break how
does that exacerbate a cloud scale well
you know we at a cloud scare we have so
many devices
policies are so complicated sometimes
you want to change one device
configuration you don't know how the
configuration will propagate and then
effects break some parts of the network
on the other side and that's the company
kissing so oftentimes the designers or
the human minds to just couldn't you
know figure out beforehand so it's very
important to really test it just before
the deployment cool we'll get into the
specifics of that in a second marina
you've been instrumental in making open
network emulator a product from your
perspective give us an overview of how
it went from research to product and
what's so great about it in your world
so bringing research ideas to Asia is a
challenge because is huge and we want
everything to be automatic any manual
work is a problem so bringing research
idea and make it inside our automatic
pipeline is a challenge requires a lot
of valid a privilege in make sure it
works but now it's great and actually
Asia is growing very fast and we're not
only adding new machines and new data
centers we are also adding more pipes
between the clusters and we just done
very big change in the network and it
was completely hitless to the customers
due to this open network emulator
because we emulated everything before we
did the change yeah so now it's a real
product yeah yeah how how our customers
experiencing it now is it still you know
is it is it fully productized and
deployed or so right now it's the
customers don't see it yet because it's
behind the scenes but from January it
will be open source and they can see the
types customer wise the external one
yeah like other companies who used
and our goal is to make them don't feel
there's anything that interfere with our
deployment are doing but there's the
internal customer who are network
operators who will use this product
internally to make sure that their voice
is reliable okay so it's already abroad
are deployed well tell us a bit more
about how it works is it easy to use is
it transparent do you need a special
degree to use me to be an expert to be
able to use an open network emulator
well for the internal customers and it
operated we made it really easy to use
we have nice UI and we have this core
one touch deployment basically go along
the web portal and choose what network
devices they want to emulate is putting
the box and then hit the button say our
email emulator the system will take up
all the rest for the external customers
to be very easy to use they will be able
to download it from either marketplace
and specify the topologies they want to
emulate with specific you know
commercial switches vendors and images
and then within minutes they can create
a huge emulated Network great so from
the research perspective Yibo what
challenges did you face when this was
just a baby idea you you started with
this idea that you need an emulator for
cloud skill networks how did you go
along that process yeah well there were
two men research challenges when to
handle heated unions switch devices or
network devices in emulation and we use
a state of virtualization techniques
including containers or VMs and
interconnect them using customized
virtual network to make the emulate here
the software feel like they are dwelling
on the real hardware and that's one of
the challenge and the other one is that
when you do this large scale or high
fidelity emulation you were swimming
find out that you have to deal with
final boundary
yeah by that I mean
because the networks all connected even
connect to the internet and you can't
afford to emulate how internet though
you may not even have policies for
outside Microsoft's Network so we have
to figure out the boundary where the
emulation can stop and after stopping
the emulation terminated and the
boundary you still need to guarantee the
correctness of the emulation because the
network devices are interacting with
each other so we have a theorem how to
improve that we can find minimum
boundary with correct correct NIST
guarantees so as this moves forward and
I wasn't even gonna ask this but as you
bring it up it's like okay there's
adding new stuff to the internet
everyday devices and networks are you
looking forward from a research
perspective on how you're going to
expand those boundaries maybe or yeah
this is advantage of the open community
the open source with it will enable us
to work with community in other vendors
or individuals can contribute to this so
the source code and add more features
and help us to make it easier genius and
support every possible vendor yeah
that's that sounds like it's not been
done before no it's not to push on these
direction that's great so what's the
goal of this open network emulator what
is our world look like if you guys are
wildly successful successful so I can
talk about in Asia we care very much
about serviceability now what happens if
we have a bug or failure how quickly fix
that and it's been a challenge for us
so having tools like that or immolations
and reducing the number of failures that
happen in real time production will help
us to grow more and look into another
layer of new challenges and you know
leaving this behind right so I realize
that since we are open sourcing these
that we hope that faculty is the
universities can also leverage these
emulate
not just to like operate our Microsoft
network but also explore and verify the
research ideas also at the classrooms
they can use it to to teach students
about network devices and then we hope
that this can become a standard tool in
the research community to carry our
networks pyramids so there's big goals
still even in research yeah as this
grows and and in product it's like hey
this is kind of game-changing for
operators academia specifically if
someone doesn't have real hardware in
the lab they can go and emulate you know
dozens of devices within seconds just
running Khan Asia you don't need to buy
the hardware and it will enable the
students to see the source code of the
switches specifically for example the
sonic virtual switch right within
minutes without having actual hardware
which is great I think it is well thanks
you too for coming in and talking to us
today and giving us an up-close look at
the open network emulator it's great
talking to you and thank you for joining
us again see you next time
[Applause]